JEANNE MOOS: The city
of Amarillo, Texas,
is asking folks to guess,
what is this thing?
The image was captured
last month at 1:25 AM
by a camera set up
inside the Amarillo Zoo,
looking out through
a perimeter fence.
"Is it a person
with a strange hat
who likes to walk at night?"
city officials asked in a
tweet, referring to it as a UAO.
- The unidentified
Amarillo object.
- Wow.
JEANNE MOOS: Let the guesses
begin, from Fantastic Mr. Fox--
- I don't wanna live
in a hole anymore.
JEANNE MOOS: --to Rocket Raccoon
from "Guardians of the Galaxy."
- Oh, yeah.
JEANNE MOOS: The camera is
motion-activated and sends
an alert to zoo officials
when it captures something,
there were some
serious theories.
MICHAEL KASHUBA: The raccoon
standing on its hind legs
or potentially a person
walking through the park
that just happened to get
captured in a peculiar way.
JEANNE MOOS: But the public's
guesses were more colorful,
from Sonic the
Hedgehog to the San
Antonio Spurs coyote mascot.
Someone tweeted the movie
"Dog Soldiers called
and want their werewolf back."
Another poster wondered,
"Is this guy on the loose?"
And, of course, there were
references to Bigfoot,
though someone
thought Littlefoot
might be more appropriate.
There is no video,
just this image.
One poster went all out to
illustrate his theory it was
a "coyote jumping the fence,"
diagrammed with anatomy
like ears, tail, et cetera.
Noted.
If nothing else,
all these guesses
could leave folks howling.
[howling]
Jeanne Moos, CNN, New York.